you've always wanted erstand what
something is calling why it is called
that what's a model the model when you
hear the word model what do you think oh
it's like a person right who has
incredible body proportions and get
spray paid to walk up and down and look
amazing all that right actually I'm told
it's a really depressing life but that
aside I've never done any loss or
something I don't worry about the idea
is I need to look at how something is
going to function in the real world
right which already because it I know
but you see clothes on a rack like I
don't know what that's going to look
like when someone actually wears it so
using more right now because I'm a bit
more of known and I friends are duties
kind of thing when I think I model I
think of this now this is actually
Sydney maybe this will be a little bit
easier this is Sydney that's circular
key down there you can just make out
center point I just try to find a
high-resolution one that I couldn't this
is Sydney it's a model it's a scale
model of the entire city dating and it's
used by civil engineers we can in fact
see the tabling of that it's on like
that's how big it extends right now the
reason civil engineers use this is
because lots of types engineer's
aeronautical chemical software a bottle
bar do they don't know what civil
engineers do buildings they are like
architects basically they're kind of
like the nitty-gritty stuff for what
architects design now it's really
important for them to have something
like this to work with because these
buildings very very tall when you build
very very tall things there are issues
that kind of crop up the dirt that
aren't really don't worry when you got
very short buildings namely the wind
right so we're here on the harbor right
we're around in the ocean the sea is
like over here all of this incredible
wind is coming into the city and it's
affecting these buildings right I don't
know if you have a look at the center
point and thought about how ridiculous
that thing looks right like can you
imagine if you had like a really tall
object and you try to rest on your head
just to demonstrate how right take a
toll on Jay and just try and rest it on
your hand so that it stays still now it
is incredibly difficult I know you might
think arts just because sir smoker right
in a minute I'll get you guys to have a
go at this yourself and you'll discover
how difficult it is to take a toll on
tech and have it stay stable and then
you look at something like that how does
it do that answer on water engineering
and a lot of testing with the wind now
is the problem as an engineer you cannot
spend billions trillions of dollars
making your building and then kind of
every day just crossing your fingers and
her drink it does not blow over okay you
need to test on a model beforehand right
so this is actually this particular lot
of it's in a wind tunnel and they're
literally siphoning through here and
they test out above this let's put this
here what if we did an 80 story and we
did it over there would that work would
it be better if I was here what's the
maximum i can build okay so modeling is
about saying take something that's kind
of like the real world yeah this time
you could go that way I've started take
something which is not exactly the real
world but it gives you a good enough
idea how the reward function is that you
can draw some conclusions of it you can
say yeah it's alright i'm pretty
confident we can do center point and
it's not gonna fall the heap okay so
this is what motors out maybe you want
to write that down with me right
mathematical models because that's what
we're look not the matical models are
don't guess the way out says there are
approximations of the real world
approximations of the real world no one
thinks oh this is exactly how the how
the sydney CBD is going to function
right like this thing is i don't know
what the scale is it's it's several
hundred to one so it's much much smaller
otherwise it'd be impractical so all
this is an approximation of the real
world but if your approximation is good
enough you
draw conclusions from it right there are
approximations of the real world that we
can draw practical conclusions from
for example where can you build a
building how tall to go to be now where
do you think the linear content that's
about yep sorry it's missing I mean I'm
mathematical models are approximations
are the real other we can draw practical
though they are counting you have a look
at something like this let's go okay so
we're going to work with this right now
this is a linear model this thing here
of printing costs versus number of books
that are produced by a certain polish
it's a mini model cause it up straight
line okay if not their real well but
it's close enough that we can redraw
some decisions on it I'll make some
decisions on it and draw some
conclusions from it yes I I don't think
so well i'm going to say accurate I
think it's made up but it's you know
it's not like ridiculous I think it's I
guess it depends on how many things you
may like it is a simplified version i
will say in fact in reality when the
number of books increases and we talk
about things called economies of scale
so you guys are if you buy in bulk you
can buy for less right liked each
individual unit will cost less so in
fact a more realistic graph might not be
exactly straight but it's close enough
to straight that I can still use this to
draw some conclusions rock which is
exactly what I'm going to do right now
okay so have a look at this graph models
printing costs identify the dependent
and independent variable is the easy
part what are the two things being
compared and which one is which any
takers
okay okay now I'll give you a bit of a
clue right it's kind of 5050 right which
access to we usually use for the
independent variable the one that we
change we tend to use X we tend to read
it that way and say okay if you give me
a number of books I will give you the
cost okay generally speaking so I'm
actually gonna call this one the
independent and this one the depuy okay
so maybe for Part A you want to write
down jenos we can we would say the
number of books that's what the cost
depends on right it's like are you want
to do four hundred books this is how
much it'll cost you as opposed to be
over that even though we'll post both
those mushrooms so power beans in the
normal phrase you find the cost of 2,500
bucks okay what are we going to do have
a look at your horizontal axis which is
with a book axis right there's 500 right
there so I'm going to read that up it
looks to me if I go all the way up along
this grid line I'm gonna end there you
happy with that that's 500 books now you
re across to here look carefully don't
you say that's equal to it looks like
it's just above it looks like it's just
about this line do you agree with that
do you see it's just above that non line
ringing across so my question is what
does that line well what does that point
on the axis yes 4250 right because it's
halfway between 4505 done so in fact i'm
gonna write is who's my example you guys
are even done ate the pie be I would say
it's just above 4,000 750 just the ball
now this is and Gary mentioned this
before it's like well it's a bit hard to
read it's not exactly on but we can make
sail it's okay it's an approximation so
i'm going to pick a number that's just
above it's not at five thousand i'm
going to say about 4,800 okay now we
were talking in a future topic about
what we call greatest possible error I'm
from percentage error the limits of
accuracy their autograph if we're in the
right ballpark i think we're okay if you
read for there's a 715 I don't think
that would be all right why not because
it is clearly not on the line I don't
know how much it's not on the line but
it can't be on the line if I wrote like
five thousand or so wrong you've got way
too far but I mean the reasonable range
okay so there's a bit of care that's
acceptable in